nos collègues de l'otan et le secrétaire
général stoltenberg quand il déclare que
ils sont ouverts au dialogue au avec la
russie en fait leur dialogue pour eux
c'est simplement de promouvoir leurs
positions notamment sur le cren
d'ailleurs le le sommet les sommets
l'édition sommet russie américains ne se
sont jamais tenues sans qu'il y ait un
certain nombre de revendications sur le
sur la question but craignent and or ce
que nous avons encore rappeler ici à
munich c'est que de le l'otan n'a rien à
voir avec l'ukraine
il est pour l'ukraine il y a le format
normandie qui a été mis en place avec
l'allemagne et la france
d les américains ont cherché à être
impliqué dans les dialogues avec les
autorités ukrainiennes mais sur les
discussions mais encore une fois on voit
que l'otan attend le cren les bras
ouverts mais en même temps sap tous les
efforts visant à respecter les accords
de minsk mais pour ce qui est parlé d
autres sujets je les dis je les rappeler
aux as
stoltenberg s'est justement l'otan qui a
cessé
presque toutes les formes de coopération
notamment en matière de lutte contre le
terrorisme et notamment en afghanistan
et mais aussi d'une manière plus
générale sur l'ensemble de la planète et
tout notre coopération précédente
aujourd'hui il ya disparu donc
et l'otan fait semblant de croire que il
a une qu'elle a une démarche positive et
pour convoquer de nouveau le sommet
russie otan pour discuter de questions
de vote cela me paraît pas très
professionnel donc si nous menons un
dialogue sur la transparence la catho
ration de la confiance et la limitation
des armements tout cela me parlait assez
vide et il ya quelques jours quand j'ai
rencontré stoltenberg ici à munich
quand je lui dis que il n'avait pas
répondu à nos questions très concrètes
il a donné des réponses tout à fait
évasive et encore une fois les questions
qui ont été posées l'année dernière par
notre chef d'état major sur les
exercices des forces de l'otan des
forces russes sur une respecter une
distance convenu silence de leur part
depuis longtemps il ya la question de la
sécurité au dessus de la zone baltes et
nos militaires ont proposé de se mettre
d'accord pour que les avions de combat
qui vole au dessus de l'espace de la mer
baltique utilisent leur transpondeur
comme le font les avions civils et
ensuite se mettre d'accord sur une
distance de rapprochement minimum tant
pour les navires militaires que pour les
aéronefs militaires de la russie et de
l'otan de nouveau silence
en face et dans ces conditions pour nous
évidemment nous voudrions suivre ce que
propose le président macron de pluie
plusieurs fois et que cela entre un peu
dans la tête de l'otan pour que est la
question qui se pose c'est de savoir si
cette tête et n'est pas malade